hello everyone I hope we're still having
an excellent Saturday we are back at the
TCC season 14 Super Final it's game 63
and it's Lila j0 versus Rakesh once
again as you know they are playing a
hundred games match and whoever wins
this match will be the TCC season 14
champion and it's again quite an
interesting game like we mentioned they
play pre-arranged openings firstly I
will now play this opening with the
white pieces then only level play this
opening with the black pieces or
stockfish will you know either way but
still very interesting and the players
will get a lot of ideas how to approach
certain openings so here we have e 4 e 6
d 4 and D 5 at the French defense and
Knight to c3 Knight to f6 and Bishop to
g5 a very rich a rich line and here we
have Bishop to b4 the the McCutchin
variation where it seems that the black
just blundered the piece but not really
ok this was too pre-arranged he 5
attacking the pin piece with H 6 and now
not capturing and after captures
captures white would just be much
stronger here but rather better back to
e3 we have night Stewie for now again
attacking the pin piece and Queen to g4
a very a very wild line so now you
cannot capture this for example Knight
captures well not winning in any
material because after Queen captures
your rook is under attack and you don't
have any good discoveries if you're
thinking about going back with a check
and then maybe just you know putting
rook somewhere c3 again you'll win back
material and now you either have to give
up the rook or save the rook and give up
the bishop but without your bishop with
so many dark square weaknesses white
white will just have a winning game so
after queen g4 we have King to f8
defending the g7 pawn and now a3 and
again big Bishop captures and c3 is
played here you cannot capture Knight
captures as it loses loses the game but
I will show it as it's very interesting
how how it loses after you capture the
bishop the knight only has one squared
the e4 square and after Knight goes here
you will at some point
trapper with f3 first you limit the
movement
to h4 you don't allow the nice to escape
via g5 as the f6 square is already
covered c5 is covered e6 is covered so
the knight isn't really going anywhere
black will go knight c6 and you can go
f3 just yet because of captures and this
would be a threat so first you just
defend your b4 pawn but then black has a
very nice area 97 then you play this but
then you get Knight to f5 your Bishop on
e3 is undefended so if you capture here
black captures here first you move the
bishop and now black plays Knight to g3
Bishop captures and now Knight e3
attacking the Queen Queen has to move
and now nice the C to check wins the
rook on a1 you move the King Knight
captures and now finally you win the
knight not Quincy 1 attacking the knight
Knight b3 and queen d1 and the night is
finally trapped so basically you get 2
pieces for a rook but - white white will
eventually win the game but yeah ok
Bishop captures on c3 and we have B
captors and c3 and Knight captures so
black wins a pawn but white it will be
ahead in development Bishop to d3 and
here when Lila was defending with the
black pieces Lila played Bishop to d7
here and Lila was able to hold the
blacks position to a draw stockfish goes
for a different line smoke which plays
b6 and it was played in human chess also
we have h4 and now there is a one game
where Bishop to e6 was played but here
Stouffer's goes Knight to c6 and now
already on move 11 we have a completely
new game so h5 limiting the movement of
blacks pieces we have Bishop to d7 and
now comes nice - E - ok Knight captures
with Queen captures and not nice - e7
and as I'm already used to Lila just
pushing pawns I was expecting g4 here
just not allowing even the f5 square of
for the white tonight but a little goes
a for first we have a 5 and now comes f4
and the knight now finally comes to f5
with Bishop to have to not allowing the
knight to capture it g4 of course can be
played in the future but now stockfish
finds a very nice idea he can just grab
at the central pawn and then push the c5
pawn to trap a little as bishop on d3 we
have worshipped cats
very nice bishop characters night and
now c5 the bishop has to move Bishop to
f2 baila and now comes c4 and the bishop
here is trapped and here you have a few
options the most obvious one is Bishop
captures you'll grab two points so you
just equalized material but then you
allow black some counter play and a
little ela isn't interested in this and
of course your king is still in the
center could be it could be somewhat
dangerous the bishop coming to b5 and
all not not something you want to do so
after c4 a little plays a bishop the g6
decides to give back the piece but you
know in a way in a way that leave us his
fee if it we have F captors and g6 pawn
captures on g6 and now you have this
problem where okay it's a game but how
does black get this rook into the game
not that's not an easy task
Kinki seven bucks a page for Czech wins
the Queen if you try something like King
e8 maybe you want to go look at fate to
try and get your rook into the game this
way then white immediately starts
lunging forward for example f5 and now
after each captures you will play even a
six brush up to c6 and now Bishop to d4
we'll just you know force first black to
keep a passive position and defend you
will go okay seven defend this pawn here
to keep an eye on d7 square as well but
a white will cast I'll bring the other
rook over to a-1 and the blacks King is
still stuck in the center this rook is
still without without a way of entering
and OK ROCK f8 it's possible but still
the in the long run black black will be
lost here
so after H captures and g6 we have King
to g8
getting the King out of the way but for
now stockfish the rook is non-existent I
mean it exists in a way that it's just
you know in in the way of stuff but okay
c3 first limiting blacks blacks mobility
and we have Queen to f8 now attacking
the f4 pawn queen to g4 and now Queen to
f5 or offering a Queen trade and lyl
accepts we have Queen captures pawn
captures and now rook the b1 attacking
the b6 pawn the bishop is already
attacking it if you captured with the
bishop then rook b8 maybe it would be
too much activity for black but
allows zero activity for stockfish Ruby
ate and now you could go for rope
captures rook captures Bishop captures
you attack the a5 porn then black will
go h5
you could you could capture this pawn
create a passport here but black can
just capture the a4 point is unguarded
this rope can now enter the game via h6
will grab the g6 pawn and so on and so
on
black want angle and will have a will
have a possibly a decent game but after
this roofed a bit move Lila finds a
different way Lila decides to not to
give up the e4 pawn but to overload the
bishop on d7 G for finally the g4 comes
into play and now it's capturing here is
not all that possible
after King d2 you have to make it
connect rooks and make some room for
your rook F Caterson g4 now rook
captures and b6 will be will be quite
excellent rook captures the Bishop
captures you will attack also the a5
pawn and now you don't really gain
anything there's there's no way to go
something like h5 the rookie six because
f5 defends the g6 pawn so here if you
try defending f5 King e8 f six is coming
and there's not all that much you can do
you can capture and then pawn captures
you have to connect that passed pawns
if King d7 f7 is coming once you get the
rook into the game rook f1 and there is
no good defense against upon to f8 you
can block with the robot then Bishop c5
just attacks that you have to move it so
after this g4 move Lilla decides to play
F captures on g4 and now another
beautiful move east six so what's the
idea now well Leela thoughtfully decided
to play Bishop captures on a4 but if
Bishop captures to e6 then rook 285
comes and then f5 will be very strong
also the rook is now coming into play
via a five and now after King to f8 I
mean you can't play the entire game
without with your rook on h8 rookie five
King to e7 is impossible now because if
King here that f5 or King gate also
loses to a5 black would just be without
a move here
white would white would just play
whatever white likes you can just bring
your King into the game improve the
position and black has no moves this
rook is out of the game the King has
nowhere to go
the bishop cannot move you have to keep
an eye on this pawn the rook cannot move
its
really doing all that much even here so
a very passive position so after each
six stop you decided not to capture it
but first a bunch of captures it's not a
problem for Lila to give up some
material as before black introduces this
rook into the game it's like Black is
playing down a look King D - we have
Bishop back to ei - going after the g6
pawn but now f5 we have b5 here now
stock fish also has a passed pawn here
but now route to a one with a for
defending and now look back to be one
the threat is of course the rook
captures on a for the rockin b8 is
unguarded so we have looked a c8 and now
push up to 84
the bishop is now coming to east 7 and
then will find us safe Square and before
where it will completely block off the
Queen side pawns but will also keep an
eye on the f8 a square for the King and
also if the rook will ever want to enter
the game g3 not a lot of thing black can
do we have kink to e3 and now Bishop the
c6 and now Bishop captures okay now the
bishop can enter the game via Bishop to
d6 we have king to f8 Bishop to d6 check
King te8 finally the King made some
space for the rook to enter the game but
now rook to f1 now f6 is a move we have
looked the d8 attacking the bishop and
now brush up the b4 now the bishop alone
is controlling the entire Queen side as
all of the pawns are on light squares
you can never pull them on dark squares
because stockfish has a a light square
Bishop witches well for the moment it's
really a pawn as there's not much you
can do with this Bishop so for the lack
of a better move d4 check deciding to
give up some material back to activate
the bishop C capture son d4 and now
Bishop to d5 blocking the d5 pawn but
now comes f6 and now if you play G
captures then you get the rook captures
and nice still no way for this rook to
enter the game you can go rook g8 trying
to block something but it doesn't it
doesn't really work rook a to F 1 and if
from g7 then you get from a fate
checkmate but any other movies is not
not enough there's not much to do and
even if you don't move the rook rook to
f8 will be checkmate for example if
anymore
faith just captures and captures will
result in checkmate at the ponies
controlling the d7 square and the bishop
is covering the dark squares so after f6
we have Bishop captures an e6 but now f7
check look at how this Bishop
beautifully controls the dark squares
King has to go to d7 or you can give up
some material but this also doesn't work
King d7 and now here is the moment where
Leela makes her a little joke f8 I would
a promotion to a look the reason why
it's a little promoted to a rook is
probably because it calculated that well
you have to calculate less variation so
with a rook and then with a queen and
it's also winning so what what's the
point of bringing up a queen ah but you
know people will always look at this as
if Leela made a joke but who knows maybe
maybe even didn't make a joke who am I
to argue with that about him either
Brooke or Queen doesn't really matter
you are now just up material so here
King to see sex was played and you know
stockfish resigned to the game or we can
say it together it was in this position
that starfish resigned in the game but
even capturing just leaves white up too
much material so finally this rooks only
move would be to capture the rook once
the game is resigned because white now
is a powerful rookie as you do have some
past points on the Queen side but the
bishop just totally dominates the dark
squares no possible controller here here
sir
after this here position stalkerish
resigned the game and yet another
wonderful victory for Leela in the
French defense and like I said when the
colors were reversed Leela was able to
hold this position with the black pieces
of where we already mentioned here
instead of b6 allah went to Bishop to d7
and was able to hold it to a draw so
very interesting and very exciting Leela
again 2 points in the lead and you know
we are getting closer and closer to the
end of the super finals very excited to
see where this goes and maybe if Lee
laughs I know he wins this it will be
you know groundbreaking stuff like I
said and then maybe who knows we will
have a Leela versus alpha match which
would I think that match would create
games so beautiful that I don't know it
just be super awesome ovid yeah I will
just have to wait and see who knows
watch the
brings I do hope you enjoyed this I
would like to thank on drag the Sony
Stefan green oxy atom son
Dimitri funda and Mark OCA for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos see her
think all for watching and I will see
you soon we will check up on Lila as far
as she's you know in this super final
again stock fish and also continuing the
capablanca saga checking up on your
suggestions and whatever comes along our
way thank you all and I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your
Saturday